okay if I'm being honest they are you
feeling I mean it's charting everyone's
talking about it what feel like I
honestly it's the most real thing in the
world because I have just been sitting
on this song for self along and I it's
just been so terrified to do anything
with it
and I finally just got the courage to be
like look the lyrics are relatable right
now for a lot of people I wrote it in a
time where I was like connected to a lot
of pain and hurt and the case anymore so
I was like uh what do I really want to
release it and then now give it the time
something we can all relate to the
lyrics from Vienna
my dad was actually in the studio with
me while I was recording that because I
was going through the breakup with Sean
at the time and it was a really really
hard time and that's kind of about a
bunch of things that was such a hard day
to get out of bed and go like record a
song sure I just was like I have to
prove to myself how resilient I am and
my dad helped so much and so he was in
the studio so for it to all come
together and be out there and and have
him know he was there with me I recorded
he's obviously so proud also if I'm
being honest I heard you saying that
isolating with your boyfriend is amazing
but that you didn't want an engagement
during isolation right you know some
kids say it's romantic but what okay
tell me your reasoning as to no you
don't want it
during corky nobody's ever asked me for
a reason now I'm like wait why don't I
want a quarantine engagement I think
because I always said I wanted a more
private engagement and what's more
private than an isolation so I guess I
wouldn't be mad I could you imagine he
does it I'm like no obviously say yes
it'd be so excited but I think I just
picture like we're just here doing our
every day today I just don't know where
or how he would do it but I always just
keep envisioning like a beach I might
not get back to the beach I don't know I
might I don't I'm not that picky
I've now that you've questioned me on it
I'm like okay I don't care